there's an absolutely stunning new
report from a longtime investigative
journalist Carl Bernstein about what is
going on behind the scenes with Donald
Trump and multiple Trump administration
officials believe number one that Donald
Trump is completely delusional on the
basis of a bunch of different phone
calls he's had with world leaders and
number two that Donald Trump's phone
calls with world leaders actually
represent a security threat and I'm
going to go through some of the
allegations I encourage you to read Carl
Bernstein's primary reporting directly
because it is really really important so
just a few highlights from from the
report multiple sources described Trump
as bullying and belittling allies while
fawning over autocratic leaders no
surprise there sources say Trump behaved
in near sadistic fashion with female
leaders that he talks to Putin as if
there are two guys in a steam bath and
that Turkish president air Dewan quote
took Trump to the cleaners
Trump's behavior was said to be so
unusual and erratic that it convinced
senior administration officials that the
president was quote delusional and this
includes officials like national
security adviser HR McMaster former of
course almost everybody's former with
Trump former national security adviser
john bolton former defense secretary Jim
mattis former Secretary of State Rex
Tillerson former White House chief of
staff John Kelly and intelligence
officials they believed that Trump was
often delusional that he was
disconnected from reality in terms of
what was going on in some cases
according to Karl Bernstein's report
Trump's actions led White House
officials to conclude that the president
posed a national security threat these
are the people who were supposed to be
the top protectors of the American
people from national security threats
many of them believed that the president
himself was the national security threat
details about phone calls
Trump would get on the phone with other
heads of state including Mohammed bin
Salman from Saudi Arabia in
including Kim jong-un the North Korean
dictator and on the phone with them
Trump would brag about his wealth about
his genius about his accomplishments
about how bad some former presidents
were the quote idiocy of former US
presidents according to multiple sources
that sounds delusional to me that seems
like not just delusional but it seems
also a weaponized narcissism is maybe a
term I would apply now as usual you know
every time you get one of these reports
including from a very respected
investigative journalist like Carl
Bernstein who understands the
journalistic process Watergate reporter
along with Bob Woodward you immediately
just get Trump followers who just say
it's all lies it's all fake news
Bernstein did this report wrote this up
and it was published by CNN you can't
trust that it's all lies none of this
goes against what we know about Donald
Trump you know if we got a report that
this was something George W Bush did I
didn't vote for george w bush I think
Bush was a terrible president but it
doesn't sound like George W Bush that he
would be bragging about his wealth and
business accomplishments you know with
the Texas Rangers or whatever oil money
whatever when getting on the phone with
with with autocratic leaders it just
wouldn't really match everything else we
knew about George W Bush Bush was a
terrible president but that's not
something he would do everything about
this report is exactly what we would
expect Donald Trump to do based on what
we already know about the guy not
surprisingly Trump would often attack
female allies of the United States who
are or were world leaders British prime
minister Theresa May German Chancellor
Angela Merkel were regular targets of
Trump during phone calls with other
leaders in addition to Merkel in May but
number one Trump would also bully Merkel
in May when on the phone with them but
sources also say Trump would regularly
bully and disparage other leaders of
allies like for example French president
Emmanuel macron Canadian Prime Minister
Justin Trudeau
Oh Australian Prime Minister Scott
Morrison the calls were quote so unusual
to German officials that German
officials did everything they could to
cover up the content of these phone
calls this is what happens when you put
a reality-show guy who's known for
firing people on camera in charge of the
United States of America it's just not
surprising there's nothing surprising
about this it's extremely disturbing it
highlights the urgency of removing this
malignant narcissist as soon as possible
but you know we saw what happened at the
Helsinki summit we saw what happened
with multiple North Korea summits every
single scandal you know it all clearly
has been pointing in this direction who
knew right that the guy who asked a
foreign country to hack his political
opponent back in 2016 who could have
predicted that he might not be the best
guy for national security so the
trumpets are going to write this off who
cares we understand what's going on we
can distinguish between a believable and
an unbelievable claim about Donald Trump
all of this falls squarely under the
bucket of very very much believable and
that gets us to our next story which
which I want to go into some detail on
if you love feeding your intellectual
curiosity but you're always struggling
to find the time check out one of my
all-time favorite apps called blink it's
blink Isleta consume an entire book on
your way home from work
they take thousands of popular
non-fiction books condense each one into
text or audio that you can get through
in just 15 minutes and you get all of
the important core ideas and information
from that book it's perfect if you don't
have enough time to do all the reading
you want to do or if you just want to
sample a book before you buy the entire
thing I recently read a brief history of
time of course by the great Stephen
Hawking this is a book that I have been
aware of for so long and other things
got in the way and it was fantastic
to check it out on blinka stinkiest has
books on politics philosophy science
they have 27 different nonfiction
categories and a subscription is only
about eight bucks
a month and you get the entire library
but you can try it totally free and get
25% off a subscription when you go to
blink is comm slash Pakman I've put the
link right underneath this video